[Music]
a decision tonight on whether a new
house of warship will be approved in a
henderson neighborhood and some
residents aren't too happy about it if
plans move forward with this it will be
built on the southeast corner of keele
and berlin victoria saha joins us with
the latest from the newsroom victoria
yeah we're talking about a hindu temple
being built in rural henderson a place
for hindus to pray but it will be open
to anyone who wants to visit some
residents say it's not the idea of the
temple that's an issue they just don't
want it in their backyard
the five-acre land sits in the middle of
a rural preservation area in henderson
an area with hundreds of ranch-style
homes secluded from the busyness of las
vegas some residents say a new temple
called ananutsa mundir could change that
when i walk out the front door of my
home there will be a temple right in
front of my face resident sherry warren
says she doesn't want the temple being
built fearing it will take away from the
rural feel of her neighborhood we have
churches on the outskirts of our area
which are fine they're beautiful but
they're on the outskirts documents show
the hindu temple proposed by las vegas
resident baba ano wants to develop the
site into a temple with accommodations
for up to 20 visitors at a time i don't
know that i have seen a lot of
indian people or hindu people here
obviously i'm very excited we live in a
very diverse world henderson resident
gareema bhardwaj is hindu and practices
her religion frequently right now the
only option that we had is in summerlin
she understands why some residents are
hesitant but hopes if plans with the
temple move forward they'll give it a
chance probably they'll get an
opportunity to experience it earlier in
the year there were concerns from
residents on the height of the dome for
the temple it has since been changed
from 47 feet to 35 feet
as we speak right now the planning
commission is gathering to vote on this
hundreds of emails have come in from
residents who are for and against it and
of course we'll be monitoring it kirsten
thank you very much victoria now the
other two hindu temples in town located
in summerlin and near silverado ranch